SPEAKER 1: Well, welcome,
everybody-- here and online--
to an extension
of our sleep week
where we are attempting to
change the culture of sleep
at Google through information
and wonderful guest speakers
such as Dr. Meir Kryger here.
I did my PhD in sleep
and circadian genetics
at Northwestern,
and Meir literally
wrote the book that anyone
would start out with.
So as close as we
have to a sleep bible,
mirror Meir wrote that.
So he has brought together
more sleep scientists
in sort of one
compendium and probably
in one place than anyone I
know, and he has graciously
spent time over the
last couple of years,
I believe, writing
a similar type book
but for everyone that's not
necessarily a scientist.
And so I will let him tell
you about that right now.
MEIR KRYGER: OK.
So before telling
you about my book,
I want to introduce myself.
I'm a professor of medicine
at Yale University,
and I've been involved in
sleep for, believe it or not,
more than 40 years.
So I've been involved in the
sleep longer than some of you
have been alive on this planet.
So I have always been
really interested in sleep,
and what I'm going
to talk about today
is what everybody needs
to know about sleep.
I'm not going to try to turn
you into a doctor or anything,
but I'm going to want you to be
able to understand that if you
or somebody in your
family has a sleep problem
that you know how to think
about it and so forth.
So I'm going to
begin as we often
do in medicine with a
case, and in the case is
a tired elected official--
a 55-year-old elected
official-- eight year history
of late night
meetings, meals, pizza,
and soft drinks in the middle
of the night for years,
would phone cabinet members
in the middle of the night.
His performance
at work plummeted,
and he started to exhibit
very poor judgment.
And I'm not talking
about Mr. Trump.
So this is a picture of the guy.
Does anybody recognize the guy?
Any guesses?
I hear-- I see people.
AUDIENCE: Clinton's
famous for fast food.
MEIR KRYGER: I beg your pardon?
AUDIENCE: Clinton was famous
for pizza and fast food
in the White House.
MEIR KRYGER: OK.
So you are right.
So this is taken
from "Newsweek" 2001.
And those of you
who are old enough
to remember when Clinton left--
in his last week in office,
he pardoned a whole bunch
of people who should never
have been pardoned, and it
caused a lot of controversy.
And this is taken from
"Newsweek" at that time.
Some close to Clinton say
he knew perfectly well
that some of the pardons
might cause a stir
and went ahead anyway.
Others believe that Clinton--
up all night, day after day--
wasn't thinking clearly.
Over the years,
Clinton had tried
to convince himself he could
get by just fine on a few hours
of sleep a night.
Time and again he
proved himself wrong.
Struggling to extricate himself
from a previous scandal,
Clinton once told a friend,
every important mistake
I've made in my life I've
made because I was too tired.
And this was an important sort
of theme of his presidency.
He was a tired president.
So what is the real problem?
I mean, Clinton is
obviously a smart guy.
He was the President
of the United States.
But his real problem
was one of ignorance,
and I'm not using this
in a pejorative way.
He simply didn't know.
He simply didn't
know the importance
of sleep deprivation.
So the public in
general does not
know the negative impact of
sleep deprivation on the brain
and on performance.
So I'm going to give
you another case now.
This is a 29-year-old
new mother.
She was a female.
She was an executive
secretary-- a 10-year history
of excessive daytime sleepiness.
In other words, being
sleepy during the day
at a time when she
shouldn't have been sleepy.
She had a 20-year history
of snoring and five years
of apnea--
which means stopping breathing--
that was observed by others.
And so I'm going to go back
again for why she saw me.
So her sleepiness had been
severe for about five years,
and the problem with her was
she was unable to stay awake
during the daytime.
And she had a new baby at
home, and she could not
take care of the new baby.
So that was the problem.
So her symptoms--
during the pregnancy--
they worsened and worsened.
When the baby was born,
it was on the small side--
only about 5 and 1/2 pounds.
She had had two
previous miscarriages,
and I'll come back to
that a little bit later.
And when she told her
doctor about her symptoms
during pregnancy,
he told her not
to do anything because it
was too dangerous to treat
sleep apnea during pregnancy.
So basically, what she
did when she slept is--
[SNORING]
[GASP]
OK.
So she made noise, then
became quiet, and then
started breathing again.
And she did this
the entire night,
and in fact, did
this every night.
So what was the problem with
the doctors taking care of her?
Again, it was one of ignorance.
Her doctor should have known
that she had a life threatening
condition that could affect
both her and her and her baby.
And again, it was really
a matter of ignorance.
So the public generally doesn't
know enough about sleep,
and the same thing is true,
by the way, for doctors.
The average doctor who
graduates from a medical school
is lucky if he or she
gets even one or two
hours of sleep in all four
years of medical school.
So the average doctor really
doesn't know a lot about sleep.
So what we're going to do today
in the next, I'm going to say,
30 minutes, is we're going
to review what everyone
should know about sleep.
And we're going to look at what
is normal, what is abnormal,
and if there's a problem,
what you can do about it.
So here's what you're
going to learn.
You're going to learn
about the importance
and benefits of sleep.
You're going to learn a little
bit about sleep stages--
in other words,
a depth of sleep.
You're going to learn something
about how much sleep do you
as an individual
need, and then we're
going to talk about
sleep deprivation.
And chances are that
many of you in this room
are sleep deprived for
one reason or another--
be it work, be it
lifestyle, be it
you have a disorder
that actually
interferes with your sleep.
And then I'm going to very
briefly cover the main sleep
conditions that we see
in the sleep clinic.
So one of the things
that we learned
about 20 or 30 years ago is
that if you don't sleep you die.
And this was research
that was done in animals--
in rodents-- and a rodent that
is sleep deprived completely
will eventually die.
And they die what I would
call a metabolic death.
In other words, they lose
weight, they eat a lot,
their fur falls out, and they
get sores all over their body.
And that's what happens.
And it probably does
happen in people,
and there aren't a lot of
examples that I can give you.
This was one that was
in the media about two
or three years ago.
This was the story of this
gentleman of Moritz Erhardt who
was an intern working
for Bank of America,
and he was found dead
after being awake
for three consecutive days--
didn't sleep at all.
And there was a
lot of controversy
about this because in
the banking industry,
there's a whole lot of
sleep deprivation, people
working crazy hours, very
long periods of not sleeping.
So this is an example
of someone where
there was no other
explanation for his death.
So why is sleep important?
It's as necessary as the water
we drink, the air we breathe,
and the food we eat to
function and live at our best.
And it's the key to health,
performance, safety.
It's very important
for safety, and I'll
come back to that later.
And also for quality of life.
So you might ask yourself,
how does the body
know how much sleep it needs,
and how does it do that?
Well, so sleep is controlled
by two separate systems,
and one system I'm calling
here the sleep/wake restorative
process that balances
sleep and wakefulness.
What that means is the longer
you're awake, the more sleepy
you become.
So if you've been
awake for 16 hours,
you're going to be sleepy.
If you've been
awake for 18 hours,
you're going to
be really sleepy.
20 hours, you'll have
to fight to actually
stay awake, and that corresponds
to an increase in your brain
of a chemical called adenosine.
And adenosine is like a
marker of sleep deprivation.
Now, does anybody
in this room use
an adenosine blocker
for their health?
OK.
How many of you had a cup
of coffee this morning?
OK.
So caffeine is an
adenosine blocker,
and the reason why caffeine
works in waking you up
is because its
effect on adenosine.
So the other thing that
controls the timing of sleep
is a circadian biological clock.
So inside our brains,
we have a clock that
actually keeps track of time.
And it regulates the timing
of sleep and wakefulness.
And as a result of these
two things acting together,
we have alertness which
varies over the 24-hour day.
So here, we have high
alertness, low alertness.
9 o'clock in the
morning, most of us
should be wide awake and alert.
And around now, many of
you are going to be tired.
You're going to have what's
called a mid-afternoon dip,
and it doesn't matter
whether you've eaten or not.
This is a function of
your circadian clock.
Then you're going to
be much more awake.
And then suddenly at
the end of the evening,
you're suddenly
going to fall asleep.
You're going to lose alertness,
and then the day begins again.
So that's how
sleep is regulated.
Two different systems-- one
depends on how much you slept,
and the other one depends
on your biological clock.
So where is this
mysterious clock?
So this mysterious
clock is found right
in the middle of the brain.
This is a cross section--
meaning a slice of the head--
and it's right here.
It's a suprachiasmatic nucleus.
It's a group of cells that are
in the middle of the brain,
and these cells have
a pacemaker function.
One can take these cells and
put them into another animal,
and we could find
that that animal is
going to have the rhythm of
the donor animal, if you will.
So it resides in the brain.
Now, how does it know?
How does something in
the middle of the brain
know what time it is, right?
So the way it knows
what time it is-- it's
affected by light and dark.
So we have sensors in the eye--
certain types of cells that
are very sensitive to sunlight.
Actually, to light in general--
not just sunlight.
And they send information to
the suprachiasmatic nucleus
and basically synchronizes it.
So every time you
wake up in the morning
and you're exposed
to light, you're
actually synchronizing
your circadian clock.
And so this is
something that we've
known about for a very
long period of time.
So it turns out that
not only does the brain
or the cells in the brain
have a built in clock,
so does every single
cell of your body.
Every cell of your body has
the genetic information in it
to actually have
a clock function.
And so all cells have a biologic
rhythm, so the liver at night
doesn't work the same way as
the liver during the daytime.
Although, I'm sure you've
never really thought
about how the liver works.
Now, how the master clock
in the brain controls
all the others is
still a mystery.
In other words, all the
clocks are synchronized.
Your liver knows whether
it's day or night,
so we don't really know
about all the connections.
And it certainly isn't via sort
of an in-body internet, but who
knows what they'll
discover one day.
So what happens if
these clocks break?
So this is a colleague of mine.
You know him-- this
is Fred Turek who
worked with the gentleman
who introduced me.
Yeah, and so look.
This is a mouse.
This is a rodent that has
a mutant circadian clock.
It becomes obese.
It develops the
features of diabetes.
And these two rodents
are actually twins.
I guess there were
a bunch of them,
so I don't know
what you call two
of a group of a
whole bunch of them.
So we know that if you
have a mutant clock,
you become very abnormal.
And there are many conditions
that can cause your clock
to either become confused-- and
I'll talk about those a little
bit later--
or to malfunction.
So normally, when
we go to sleep,
we don't just go from being
awake to being asleep.
There is a pattern that
has been recognized
for many, many years.
So when we go to bed,
we're awake for a while,
usually between 5
and 10 or 20 minutes,
and we then have a very
orderly progression
during the different
stages or depths of sleep.
And the deepest ones are down
here-- stages three and four
which we call deep sleep,
and they occur mostly
at the very beginning of
the night in the first third
of the night.
Like magic, we have--
after about 90 minutes
of being asleep--
we go into what's called
rapid eye movement sleep.
And rapid eye movement sleep is
a very, very interesting phase
because this is when we dream.
And we're also paralyzed during
rapid eye movement sleep,
which means we cannot
respond physically to what
we're actually dreaming.
And you'll see a
little bit later,
there are some diseases
where someone, for example,
has an abnormality
in the system that
paralyzes you that results
in the person acting out
their dreams.
And they can harm
their bed partner.
So we have the first episode of
dreaming at about 90 minutes,
and then we have there after,
about every 90 minutes,
another episode of rapid eye
movement sleep or dreaming.
OK.
So all of us will dream on the
average between three and five
times a night.
Most people, if they're lucky,
will remember one dream.
Many people do not remember
any of their dreams,
and in part, that
depends on whether or not
they've awakened during a
dream or in proximity in time
to a dream.
So we need consolidated sleep.
And what I mean by consolidated
is long stretches of sleep
in which we think is
very restorative for all
these reasons--
for safety, cognitive function.
If you don't sleep enough,
your cognitive function
quickly becomes abnormal.
Relating well to others--
you can almost always recognize
someone who's sleep deprived.
They're snappy,
they're irritable,
you don't want to
be around them.
And it turns out that learning
and memory consolidation
are really important in terms
of the function of sleep.
And to put it into a context
that you as engineers mostly
will understand, what
happens during sleep
is the REM, the memory and
REM, is put onto a hard drive.
In other words,
the volatile memory
is stored permanently,
and so that's
what happens during sleep--
particularly, during
rapid eye movement sleep.
And there are many
health problems
that arise in
someone who doesn't
sleep enough or properly.
So how much sleep do you need?
OK.
So most of you are going
to be in this group here.
You're going to need between
seven and nine hours,
and the range goes from
about six to about 11.
Some people will need 12,
as you'll see in a minute.
How many people here
sleep less than,
on the average, less
than seven hours?
OK.
So it looks like
about 25% of you.
So we did a survey
among students at Yale
at a sleep fair
about a year ago,
and probably about 25%
or 30% of the students
were actually sleeping
less than seven hours.
And there were
quite a few who were
sleeping less than five hours.
So it's a huge problem.
I said the word
huge, and so here we
have the current president
of the United States.
And sleep needs vary.
So this is an actual quote.
This is an actual quote.
How does someone that's
sleeping 12 and 14 hours a day
compete with someone that's
sleeping three or four?
He admitted to only sleeping
three or four hours.
And to people in
the sleep field,
this was an extremely
scary statement.
Because if you studied sleep,
three to four hours of sleep
is scary.
And so athletes-- so
tell that to LeBron James
and a lot of other athletes.
So LeBron James
sleeps 12 hours a day,
and there are many
other athletes
that sleep a great deal--
way more than what I showed
you in terms of recommendation.
And you might ask
yourself the question,
what advantage does an
athlete have in sleeping more?
So when you're looking
at a world class athlete,
everybody at that kind of
level is physically the same.
They're all in great shape,
and they're all strong,
and they're all quick.
The difference is in the brain.
And that's where the
difference resides,
and so sleep for athletes
is critically important.
It's critically important
for airline pilots.
for the people that
sit in the Google
autonomous vehicles watching
the car do its thing.
So being awake is
very important.
So people in general
in the US society
are not getting sufficient
sleep, and about 40%
of the population are
not getting the seven
to nine hours.
In the US, the average is
probably about 6 and 1/2 hours
right now among adults.
And of this 40%,
about 3/4 of them
have sleep problems
that will either
affect the quality
of their sleep
or their daytime performance.
So you might ask
yourself a question--
does monitoring sleep work?
And how many of you
here are using a device?
This is an older
model of a Fitbit.
You're using a device?
Do you find it useful?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I find it useful when it shows
me that a week has gone by
and I'm way below average.
MEIR KRYGER: Yeah.
So my question is, would
you have already have
known that anyways?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
MEIR KRYGER: OK,
and what about you?
AUDIENCE: I'm still trying
to sort out if it's reliable.
MEIR KRYGER: OK, yeah.
So these devices have
been out for a long time,
and believe it or not, there
isn't a whole lot of literature
that validates
their use right now.
And it could be that the
companies may not even be
interested in validating them--
that as long as the data is sort
of fuzzy, people will buy them
and kind of use them.
So there are many,
many gadgets out there
that purport to
monitoring your sleep.
Some of them sit by the bedside,
some of them sit in the bed,
and then there are some
that are on the wrist.
And you always have
to ask yourself, what
are they actually monitoring?
And in some cases, we're not
sure what they're actually
monitoring because they're
using proprietary systems.
Now, this one-- all of the
Fitbits use an accelerometer.
In other words, that
if there is movement,
they assume that
the person is awake.
And if there's no movement,
they assume that the person
is more or less asleep.
But anyways, we're very early
on in the use of these kind
of devices to monitor sleep.
So daytime sleepiness--
not surprisingly,
since a large part
of the population
doesn't sleep enough.
We have a lot of
daytime sleepiness,
and it affects all aspects of
our life including our work.
Now, has anybody here
ever pulled an all-nighter
where you're up all night?
OK.
It seems like everybody--
well, I'm going to say about
70% of the people in this room.
Pulling an all-nighter
is really bad.
It's, like, really bad.
And it's really bad, and it's
demonstrated on this slide
here.
I'll take you through this.
So we have a test that's called
the psychomotor vigilance task.
It's a very simple test.
The person sits in
front of a screen.
There's a light that comes on.
The person has got
to press the button.
It's about as simple a
test as you can imagine,
and there's several of
them that you can download
onto your smart devices.
So what a PVT lapse is is
that the light comes on,
and the person does
not respond at all.
In other words, the lights
are on, the eyes are open,
but there's no--
the person is not responding.
So in this research,
which was done
at the University of
Pennsylvania, they took people
and they slept different numbers
of days in a very controlled
environment.
So these guys slept for
eight hours a night.
They were in bed for
These people were in bed
for six hours a night,
four hours a night, and these
were people-- all-nighters.
So you'll notice that
the all-nighters,
after one night of not sleeping,
already had a lot of lapses.
So what that means,
basically, is that they
had what we call microsleeps.
When you're asleep, you
basically become blind,
and you don't see, and you
certainly don't respond.
And these episodes can
be extremely short,
which makes them
very, very dangerous.
So look at someone who
only sleeps six hours.
So here, that person
is after about a week,
and they're starting
to become abnormal.
And after about 10 days,
they are practically
as abnormal as someone
who's been up all night.
In other words, what
they have is a sleep debt
that's getting bigger
and bigger every night
to the point where they now have
trouble because they are now
physically impaired.
Now, the reason why
this is important
is that the person
who's sleep deprived
may actually not
have any perception
that there's a problem--
may not have any perception
that there's a problem.
And I'll give you an
interesting example
where performance goes down.
I think some of
you have probably
participated in a hackathon.
OK.
So I did a course at Yale--
a course on sleep.
One of the students was
a computer science guy,
and he did a very simple
experiment during a hackathon.
And what he looked at--
and the participants
didn't know this,
which drove me crazy
because it should
have gone to an IRB, an
Institutional Review Board.
What he looked at was
the code that the people
were writing versus whether
they had to be corrected.
And what he found is that in
the first 12 hours of this
hackathon-- and it went on
for like 24 or more hours--
is that the code that was being
written in the first 12 hours
was OK.
But following the 12
hours, all of a sudden,
the coders were actually
correcting code as opposed
to writing new code
that was actually good.
So their performance
really, really
dropped after about 12 hours.
And to him, that
was kind of a lesson
because he was not aware that--
so if you're up for
18 hours coding,
you do not have the
perception that your abilities
have actually dropped.
So that's very important.
It's a little bit like having
a little bit too much alcohol.
You may not be aware that
you're actually impaired.
So cognitive abilities
and mood are affected.
Memory is affected if
you haven't slept enough.
Paying attention to
and completing tasks
is very abnormal.
Mood is impaired.
People tend to become
irritable, snappy, depressed
when they're very, very sleepy.
And safety is compromised.
And I know people
fall asleep driving,
and it's a very,
very common problem.
I won't go into a
whole lot of details,
but one of the potential
great things about autonomous
vehicles is that autonomous
vehicles-- the software
will not get tired.
Maybe the person who's
supposed to be in the car
is going to get tired,
but the software
is going to continue to operate.
And so in 10, 20, 30
years when many of us
will probably be sort of sitting
in an automobile that is really
driving itself, theoretically,
that's safer than the person
actually driving,
especially if you're
driving a very long distance.
And this is something I'm sure
that your company or Waymo is
working on.
So there are health
consequences of poor sleep.
Body systems associated with
major diseases such as diabetes
are affected.
People tend to
become overweight,
and we know that the immune
system doesn't function as well
when you're sleep deprived.
For example, if you vaccinate
someone for influenza
and they've been sleep deprived,
their response to the vaccine
is not as vigorous
when they have
been sleep deprived compared
to if they've slept normally.
Common Circadian
Disorders-- shift work,
I don't imagine anybody here
is an actual shift worker.
Although, I'm guessing many
of you control your own hours.
Shift work is
really like jet lag
except it's a lot less fun
than going to another place.
So when you see
your own doctor--
when you see your own doctor,
ask yourself the question,
when was the last
time your own doctor
asked you anything about sleep?
And these are some of the things
that the doctor should really
explore--
do you snore?
Do you or others--
has anybody observed
you to stop breathing?
Do you fall asleep when you
shouldn't-- watching TV,
driving, and so forth?
Do you have difficulty sleeping
more than three nights a week?
Do you have an unpleasant
tingling or creeping sensation
in your legs when
you're trying to sleep?
And are there things that
interrupt your sleep?
And there's a gazillion things
that can interrupt your sleep--
heartburn, bad dreams, pain,
discomfort, noise, you name it,
your dog, your cat,
all of these things
can interrupt with your sleep.
So what do we see
at a sleep clinic?
And I just want to
give a shout-out here.
Dr. Rafael Pelayo is here from
Stanford, and he's right there.
And Stanford, believe it or
not, the very first real sleep
clinic in the world
was at Stanford.
What was it, about 1970?
AUDIENCE: 1970.
MEIR KRYGER: Yeah, 1970.
And it's the sleep clinic
in the United States.
And so what do we see
in a sleep clinic?
What are the complaints that
people are coming in with?
The number one thing that we
see is daytime sleepiness.
In other words, somebody
falling asleep at the wrong time
in the wrong place, or unable to
focus and concentrate, snoring,
insomnia-- and I'll cover all
of these very briefly in a few
minutes--
and weird behaviors.
And I'll go into some of the
weird behaviors in a minute.
So what are the diagnoses?
They're listed here, and I'm
going to mention all of these.
So don't worry
about it, and there
won't be a test at the
end of this session.
So we see it's something
called obstructive sleep apnea
where people stop breathing.
We see insomnia-- difficulty
in falling asleep and staying
asleep, restless leg syndrome
where the person can't
get comfortable because their
legs are driving them crazy
as they're trying to sleep.
Narcolepsy-- a condition
usually starting off
in the teenage years,
resulting in very, very
severe sleepiness.
And something called REM
sleep behavior disorder
where people respond to what
they are actually dreaming.
So snoring-- how many
people here snore?
OK.
So there's four or five
people here who are snoring.
So snoring is caused by
a blockage of breathing
when you're sleeping.
It's extremely common.
About 90 million Americans
supposedly snore.
It's more common in
those who are overweight,
have a big neck, a long,
thin face, and a small jaw.
And those are some of the things
that contribute to snoring.
Now, normally, we
don't worry a whole lot
about snoring unless the snoring
is associated with something
else or is a symptom
of something else,
and the main symptom that we
worry about is sleep apnea.
Whoopsy daisy, here.
It is sleep apnea,
and sleep apnea
is extraordinarily common.
In this condition,
people stop breathing
because their upper
airway actually obstructs.
It's found in 18 million
Americans-- probably 12 million
males, 6 million females.
And when you stop breathing,
your blood oxygen level
drops, puts a strain on the
heart, raises blood pressure.
So all of these bad
things are happening
when you stop breathing, so it's
something that we worry about.
This was the old stereotype of
someone who had sleep apnea--
an obese middle-aged gentleman,
but we see it in teenagers.
These are all patients of mine.
You see it in teenagers.
You see it in people that have
a small lower jaw, for example,
and that's actually a
very common cause of sleep
apnea both in adults
and also in children who
have what you might
call a big overbite
or what we might
call an overjet.
And so that, again,
is quite common.
So how do we treat sleep apnea?
We treat them with a mask
that fits over the nose.
This is actually a video
that's not making any noise.
Can you see her chest moving?
Anyway, so basically,
this is something
that we see all the time.
Every single clinic
that we have,
we see one or two
or three patients
that have this condition.
So where are we now?
So over the last 30
or 40 years, there
has been a big change in our
therapy of this condition.
The first treatment
that we used to use
was putting a hole in
the throat right here.
It's called a
tracheostomy which avoided
the upper airway
breathing passage,
and it was very effective but
obviously, very, very invasive.
In the first patient
that I ever had,
that's how we
treated that patient.
And so there have been all
of these other technologies
that I'm not going to go
into, but the most interesting
recent one has been
hypoglossal nerve stimulation.
So the hypoglossal nerve is a
nerve that goes to the tongue.
And so a couple of years ago, a
company came out with a system
that actually
stimulated that nerve,
and the system is based on a
pacemaker-like device right
here and one lead that goes
down to between the ribs which
indicates--
it's got a pressure transducer
that indicates whether or not
the person's trying to breathe.
And then the pacemaker
says, uh-huh, the guy
is trying to breathe.
I'm going to push
the tongue forward,
and that is in
fact what happened.
So there's a sensing of
inspiration, the pacer fires,
and it stimulates the branch
of the hypoglossal nerve,
and it actually pushes
the tongue forward--
pushes the tongue forward.
So this is a
treatment that's been
in use for a couple of years.
It was approved by the
FDA roughly two years ago,
and you're going to hear
more and more about it.
It doesn't work in someone who's
really dramatically overweight,
however.
So this is how we
treat sleep apnea,
and I've mentioned
all of these before.
And I'm going to zip
through to insomnia.
So insomnia is
difficulty in falling
asleep, awakenings during the
night, can't get back to sleep.
And also, the feeling of,
I've been in bed all night,
I wake up, I feel
like I haven't slept.
And it's the sensation--
that perception--
of inadequate sleep that
many people complain about.
How common is it?
During the course of the year,
about 40% of the population
will complain about this.
However, in only about--
not only, this is a lot of
people-- between 10% and 15%
of the American population has
insomnia on a chronic basis.
So if this were the course
that they teach at Stanford
and someone in the audience fell
asleep, they would be squirted.
Anyways, I'm not
going to do that here.
I'm not going to do that here
because the students here
are not paying to come
and listen to me here,
so that's fine.
So who's at risk
of having insomnia?
So it's women-- women
are almost twice
as likely to have
insomnia as men.
Older adults are, again,
very likely to have insomnia,
and it's not just purely age.
It's age, plus
diseases they may have,
plus medications that they
may be taking that may
be causing the problem.
And people with certain
mental disorders--
for example, depression--
are much, much
more likely to have insomnia.
So how do we treat insomnia?
Well, sometimes
insomnia is actually
associated with
another condition,
and the other condition can
be, as I mentioned, depression,
chronic obstructive pulmonary
disease, arthritis, heart
failure.
So we almost always will treat
that additional condition.
There are pharmacologic
treatments.
The over-the-counter
medications are either
going to be melatonin and/or
a Benadryl-type compound--
a sedating anti-histamine.
And the over-the-counters are
not terrifically effective
sleeping pills.
And the most commonly
used treatment now
is behavioral
treatment, and I'm not
going to go into this except to
say that we call it cognitive
behavioral therapy.
And it's done by psychologists
who have additional training,
and one of the world's experts
in cognitive behavioral therapy
is at Stanford--
Dr. Manber, Rachel Manber.
So restless legs syndrome--
an irresistible urge
to move the legs
when you're sleeping.
Anybody here have that?
You have that?
OK, your friend has that.
OK.
So restless legs
syndrome is interesting.
It's found in probably about
10% to 15% of the population.
It can be genetic.
It can run in families.
Very common in people of a
French-Canadian background,
for example.
And it's a
neurological disorder,
and I don't know whether
the video-- oh, the video
is working.
So the lady on the left--
OK, the lady on the
left, she feels hot.
When we measure the
temperature of her legs,
they feel perfectly normal.
And so it's almost like
what we call a neuropathy.
There's something-- that is, she
has the perception that there's
something abnormal going on.
When we take a patient
with this complaint
and we monitor
them during sleep,
I don't know if you
noticed, but this gentleman
had a twitch in his legs
about every 20 seconds.
Had a twitch in his legs
And so that's what people with
restless legs syndrome do,
and it's not a whole lot of
fun to be in the same bed
with someone who moves a lot
like this, as you can imagine.
So narcolepsy is a
very common condition
in a university setting.
For example, at
Yale, we have a lot
of patients with narcolepsy.
Why?
Because it usually
begins in people
who are young adults or late
teenagers, and the symptom
is severe daytime sleepiness.
In other words, they're
sleepy 100% of the time,
and suddenly, they may lose
muscle tone and collapse.
We call that narcolepsy,
and the collapse
occurs in response to
hearing a joke, becoming
angry, or excited, and they
also will have very vivid dream
imagery as they're
falling asleep
or even after they've
awakened in the morning.
Remember, I mentioned
before that we
don't have our first episode
of rapid eye movement sleep
until 90 minutes?
These patients will have dreams
actually at the beginning
of the night and sometimes
before they're actually asleep.
So it's a chronic disorder.
It's an immunological
disorder in humans,
and we're actually fairly
good at treating it.
We can't cure it,
but we can treat it.
And we can get rid
of the symptoms.
Oh, so this is a gentleman
that has REM sleep behavior
disorder.
I mentioned before that people
are paralyzed during REM sleep,
and some people are not.
Keep looking at
this guy up there.
He's starting to twitch
and he's dreaming.
He's dreaming he's
being attacked.
So this is a very
frightening symptom
to anybody who's in the
same house as this patient.
And over the years,
I've had patients
who have been hurt by
their bed partner who
had a dream that they
were being attacked,
and they were, therefore,
attacking the person sleeping
next to them.
So this condition is common
in people with a disease
that's called
Parkinson's disease,
and many without Parkinson's
disease will develop during
the course of their lifetime--
who have this symptom--
another what we call
neurodegenerative disease.
And it can lead to
injuries if it's untreated.
So sleep problems can
be an important issue,
and the reason why your doctor
needs to ask you about things
is that we can treat
all of these conditions
that I've mentioned.
And we're pretty good
at treating them.
So if anybody here
has any symptom,
the Stanford Sleep
Clinic in Redwood City
is like world famous, and that's
where you ought to be going.
So at the sleep center,
what do they do?
They do a test that's called
polysomonography where
they measure a bunch of things.
This can be done
either in the lab
itself or you could be sent home
with equipment to monitor you
at home.
Whoopsy daisy.
So there's a test that
is done that measures
daytime sleepiness.
So for example, if
someone is driving a truck
or is a pilot who has a
condition where there's
a concern about whether
they can stay awake or not,
we could document objectively
whether they are sleepy.
And these are the
treatments that are
available through the clinic.
So I'm going to end
by just saying this--
sleep is a basic biological
need, and you need to have it.
And you need to have
the right amount of it.
If you don't sleep
enough, there are
serious negative consequences.
Your doctor should identify
if you have a sleep problem.
And the only way
to identify it is
for he or she to
ask you the question
or for you to bring it up.
And how many people do you
know who have a sleep problem,
and how many of them
have been diagnosed?
Anybody here have
a family member
who is being treated
for a sleep problem?
OK, it's about three
or four of you.
Any of you know people
that probably have a sleep
problem that should be treated?
OK, so a whole bunch more
hands, which sort of brings
up the point that many
people with sleep disorders
have not been diagnosed.
So I'm going to
end this segment,
and we're now going
to be interactive.
And I think what we're going
to do is take questions,
and we'll see how far we can
get on with the questions.
So most of you have
gotten this handout.
And this handout
is from my book,
which is "The 13
Commandments for People who
are Having Trouble with Sleep."
But I want to hear from you.
I want you to ask me
questions, and I'll
do my best to answer them.
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about the mid-afternoon lull.
Is it known what
the function of that
is, or evolutionary advantage,
or any recommendations
with what we should do when
we're experiencing that?
MEIR KRYGER: Well,
so the question
is, does the mid-afternoon
lull have any function?
And the answer is, I don't know
if it has any positive function
or not.
But it is there,
and it's a function
of our circadian rhythm.
And if you feel that
you're having an afternoon,
sort of, reduction in alertness,
probably the smartest thing
to do if it's affecting you--
for example, your work, your
concentration, your driving,
and all of a sudden you're
exhausted-- the best thing
to do is to take a nap of
about anywhere between 15
and 30 minutes.
And it'll refresh
you, but you have
to be aware of this
mid-afternoon lull
because it can really
affect your performance.
Yeah, so I'm going to give
the mic to Dr. Pelayo.
RAFAEL PELAYO: Just a
little speculation on that--
the inherent paradox of sleep
is that sleeping animals can
be attacked while
they're sleeping,
and our predators like
to attack us at night.
So we have a surge of
alertness in the evening,
and our predators will
stagger to attack us
in the afternoon which
happens in a lull.
So I think what we're
doing is, we have a lull,
so later, we have a surge later.
So it compliments that.
It's just speculation.
AUDIENCE: Following
up on that premise,
wouldn't that suggest that
napping in the afternoon
is really the right
thing to do from
an evolutionary standpoint?
RAFAEL PELAYO: Yeah.
Yeah.
We agree napping is good.
MEIR KRYGER: Napping is good.
Napping is really good.
A long nap is not good.
So if you nap two
or three hours,
you're going to wake
up feeling really
groggy because of a phenomenon
that's called sleep inertia.
So the ideal length
of a nap is probably
somewhere between
30 and 40 minutes.
AUDIENCE: I always wake up
with an alarm or silent alarm,
are there any
guidelines like not
to have it fire off
in the middle of REM
or things like that?
MEIR KRYGER: Well,
there are gadgets
that claim that they wake
you up during the ideal time.
But in reality,
unless they're somehow
monitoring your brain waves
and your eye movements,
they really don't know
whether you're in REM sleep.
There are several devices
that claim to do that.
The data suggests that if you
wake up from very deep sleep,
you're going to wake
up feeling groggy,
and probably the
best thing to wake
up from is rapid
eye movement sleep
or a lighter stage of sleep.
But you'll only
have very deep sleep
usually in the first
third of the night
unless you're
sleeping like a cat--
two or three hours here, two
or three hours there, and so
forth.
AUDIENCE: So basically,
there's nothing
that I can do to predict it?
Like 7 and 1/2 hours
or something like that.
MEIR KRYGER: Well, I
mean, the ideal way
to know whether you're
getting enough sleep
is how do you feel
when you wake up,
and how do you feel
during the day?
If you wake up feeling
good, wide awake, and alert,
you have gotten enough sleep.
AUDIENCE: So I did
have a period where
I was sleeping regularly very
little-- like 3 and 1/2, 4
hours.
And now switch-- but I
don't feel any difference,
to be honest, just because the
people told me it's unhealthy.
And it dates way back
to military time,
so why am I not
feeling different,
and is it possible that some
people can get away with--
MEIR KRYGER: It is possible--
AUDIENCE: And stay healthy?
I mean, I'm doing it just
because of what I read,
what I hear.
MEIR KRYGER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Not because
I felt groggy.
MEIR KRYGER: So it is
possible that three or four
hours of sleep out of
24 is OK, but I don't
want to be flying my airplane.
In other words, that
for the average person,
three to four hours
is simply not enough
and they're impaired.
And they may not be aware
that they are impaired.
So that's what the big concern
is from a public health
perspective.
AUDIENCE: So a question
to follow up on that--
what could any of
us do to bridge
the gap between our subjective
feeling of whether we're
performing well and knowing
whether we're actually
performing well?
So I might feel OK
in the afternoon,
but I can't measure a 20%
dip in my performance.
It's just how I feel.
MEIR KRYGER: Strangely enough,
other people in your home
can probably tell when
you're sleep deprived,
and sometimes,
asking those people
or asking even colleagues--
you know, how am I doing?
Do you think I've slept enough?
May actually give you
additional useful information.
If you wanted to try to
get objective information,
you can actually
download one of the apps
that I mentioned
where you can actually
measure your own reaction time.
And you could see
how you compare
to a very big population.
But other people can usually
tell when you're really tired.
And this is something that
we see in a hospital setting
all the time.
So when I've attended
an internal medicine
and we're making
rounds in the morning,
there's been someone
who's been awake all night
and the day before
taking care of patients.
And very often, they
may not perceive
that they're doing
anything abnormal,
but the other
people in the group
can tell that the person
doesn't remember things,
is making mistakes.
So it's always good to
have other people around
to sort of be there to
kind of let you know
whether you're performing well.
AUDIENCE: In a chance that we
do have to pull an all-nighter
or maybe even get three,
four hours of sleep a night,
what is the best way
to recover from that?
Is it to add like one additional
hour for the rest of a week?
Or do we try to get 14 hours
of sleep the next night
to recover?
MEIR KRYGER: I think that's
a very personal thing.
And I know that for myself,
if I've lost a lot of sleep
in a given night-- let's say
I'm going overseas or something,
and I'm on one of these six-hour
flights and you only get
to sleep like four or
something like that--
I find that the next day,
getting a really long night
of sleep starting at the
bedtime of my destination
is the best thing that I can do.
And very often when
I do that, I will
sleep 10, 11, maybe even
12 hours during that night.
So it's a very,
very personal thing.
If catching up is an extra
hour, but that extra hour still
doesn't put you into
the normal range,
you're not going to correct.
So you have to make sure that
the sleep that you're actually
getting is going to correct
your sleep deprivation.
AUDIENCE: OK,
snoring, sleep apnea,
and restless legs
syndrome are all true.
Insomnia is not there.
MEIR KRYGER: Oh, I
should put insomnia.
We can treat insomnia.
I'll have to make
that correction.
And the way we treat insomnia
is what I mentioned--
is the first thing
we do is what we
call cognitive
behavioral therapy
and sleep hygiene, which
is some of the stuff that's
on the sheet that was
actually handed out.
And so giving sleeping
pills is not the first thing
that we do when
someone has insomnia,
it's the last thing that we
do when someone has insomnia.
We want to make
sure that we cover
any comorbidity or any other
disease that they may have,
and we've corrected
their sleep hygiene,
and we've done what we call
cognitive behavioral therapy.
AUDIENCE: So I sleep--
I need like four or
five hours and wake up
naturally after that.
Like, I'll go to sleep at 10.
I'll naturally just wake up at
2:00 or 3:00 in the morning.
I go to sleep at midnight,
I'll naturally wake up
a 4:00 to 5:00.
MEIR KRYGER: So you
sleep four out of 24?
AUDIENCE: Four to five
hours out of 24, yeah.
MEIR KRYGER: Yeah, I
mean, there are people--
AUDIENCE: Like, I
don't set an alarm.
I just wake up.
MEIR KRYGER: Yeah,
there are people
that can get away with
that, and getting away
may not be the right term.
There are some
people who naturally
seem to function on a
small amount of sleep.
And the only way to sort of
know whether you might need more
sleep is for you to participate
in one of these research
studies where they
keep you in a bed,
and if you fall asleep over
and above the four hours,
that's going to tell me--
because the only way you fall
asleep is if you need sleep.
If you don't need to sleep,
you will never fall asleep.
In other words, if you're
wide awake and alert,
it just isn't going to happen.
So that's why that
study that I showed you
from the University
of Pennsylvania
was so interesting in
that when you force people
to stay in a bed, they
actually will sleep
if they're sleep deprived.
AUDIENCE: My wife is a
nurse, and she works nights
for the last eight months.
And it's been a
train wreck, so this
is all kind of close to home.
So she goes to sleep and sleeps
four or five hours as well
and wakes up naturally and
can't fall back asleep.
So that's usually
between 1 and 2 o'clock,
and then we have small children.
So she'll sleep again
between like 7:30 and 10:00,
and that's the rhythm
she's been following.
And there's some other
things we've been doing,
but it doesn't
seem to be working.
MEIR KRYGER: Yeah, so it's a
very tough problem, and one
of the things you
might consider--
well, there's two
things to consider
in that kind of situation.
Number one is to seek help
from a sleep disorder center
where they're used to dealing
with this kind of thing.
And number two-- and
what I advise people--
is see if you can get
a permanent day job.
There are some people who
just can't adapt to unusual--
not unusual-- to schedules
that are not in sync
with their own circadian clock.
There are many people
who are night people.
And for example, if you look
at people in the entertainment
business--
these are people who go to bed
2, 3, 4 o'clock in the morning.
They love it.
They wake up at 10:00,
11:00 in the morning-- noon.
And so that's their
natural rhythm.
So what I advise
people is try to find
a job that is in sync
with your natural rhythm,
and you're going to
feel a lot better.
And depending on your
family's circumstances,
that may or may not be
practical, but in the long run,
it's something that I recommend.
And I recommend it for
a couple of reasons.
Besides the fact that it
can acutely cause problems,
chronically, I've
seen a lot of patients
who are nurses who've
worked for 30, 40 years,
and they've had these
terrible shifts.
And once they retire,
many of them will be under
the impression that all their
sleep problems are going to go
away and they don't.
So that's something
else to consider
is the long-term implications
of working nights,
and there's a lot of data coming
out that working nights may not
be good for overall
health besides, sort of,
cognitive functioning.
SPEAKER 1: Also, your book
was just released last week.
MEIR KRYGER: It was
released a week ago today.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, and
what's the name of it?
MEIR KRYGER: The name of the
book is "The Mystery of Sleep",
and the purpose of the book is
to arm people with information
that if they or
somebody in their family
has a sleep problem,
what they need to do.
And the most important
thing that people need to do
is to make sleep a priority.
In other words, that
you shouldn't ignore it.
You shouldn't denigrate it.
Don't aim for
sleeping two or three
hours like a lot of people do.
Make sleep a priority
in your life,
and you'll feel a lot
better and be healthier.
SPEAKER 1: All right.
Well, great, join me in thanking
you for being here today
and sharing some of
that knowledge with us
here at Google.
MEIR KRYGER: It was great.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]